[Music]
should i set it up yeah you should set
it up i'm calling uh of course he's the
uh international man of mystery the
founder of mcafee uh virus software uh
former uh ceo and the founder the
creator of the program uh john mcafee
hey john we got you
yeah and you know i was saying that a
couple weeks ago there was a little
scare there on twitter where you where
you were offline for for a while uh and
uh you took a nice picture in a was was
that a jail that you were in
well absolutely
it was certainly not the hilton no
well i mean it depends
it might be it might have been a motel
it could have been a hyatt a hyatt yeah
there you go
in the hyatt okay no actually it was the
dominican republic jail okay actually
not one of the worst i've been
uh it's you know far better than most
third world jails i'll be frank i've
been in most third world jails so i do
have uh something to compare it to it
wasn't bad i mean four days in detention
janus janice didn't take it as well as
as the boys did that's
me and
and my staff who were with me my
security and others who were in the cell
uh with me
janice was in with 40 strange women who
spoke only spanish and did not enjoy
herself however we're not there now and
we're in a lovely
uh you know
uh
partly warm location uh it gets up to
the mid 50s during the day which is
spectacular
um so uh we're uh we're enjoying
ourselves am i the only one though that
would probably er er just anybody press
one in the chat if you would read a book
written by john mcafee oh no where he
reviews caribbean jails oh yeah
absolutely for you know what i mean you
could just write over because like the
chapter is a different like you know the
food was all right but really it was
like leaking every night it was cold i
would read that book in a heartbeat
you know i'm i'm at the whims of the
forces of the world listen you know i
tell the truth as i see it or i just
tell it as i see it that's the most
dangerous thing in life to do
and when you do that you make
way more enemies than friends and in
fact many of your friends will simply
abandon you nobody wants to see it as it
is everybody lives in a dream so
however
i'm old it's i i don't have the energy
to tell deceptive things anymore because
you got to remember that [ __ ]
ryan who can remember a lot
so
so so anyway i'm at the mercy of my
enemies which are you know multitudinous
uh and so they just drive me i'm like
cattle i can't get driven here and there
now you know when you say when you say
enemies
when you say enemies like who are you
who are you referring to
oh jesus christ i mean which period in
my life well currently let's see let's
say currently let's see good point
currently
one of my first really large enemies was
the belgian government that spent a
month and a half with the entire army
and police force searching for me
um
because i had uh you know i maybe i did
something wrong i tapped into all of the
government computers i had a reason to
do so so please don't judge me here
looking for something i didn't find i
did find some horrible facts you know
that the the prime minister had ordered
the murder of 30 or 40 of his uh
his associates in business
uh that the minister of national defense
was the largest drug dealer in central
america that the minister of immigration
was the largest human trafficker i mean
this is pretty horrific [ __ ] to find out
um and unfortunately one of the women
that i was living with and who was
working
reducing all that data slept with the
minister of national defense and
idiot that she was she told him what she
was doing not to hurt me but innocently
you know she
she didn't know in any case that's a
long story so that's one enemy
are you still with me yeah all right
trust me trust me when i tell you you
have our undivided attention and just a
side note for people listening at home
to the uh is it the prime minister of
belize what's the head of state over
there
the guy uh the head of is the president
or prime minister
prime
so that's another one
i pissed off the bahamas government
because i discovered that the chief of
police there was one of the most corrupt
people in the world and being the person
i am i can't keep my mouth shut but it
was in headlines in all the newspapers
when i released his private bank account
a number his private bank uh his
deposits yeah his rece you know receipts
uh the cash that he took out
uh well that bastard came after me
uh cuba threw me out uh dominican
republic i [ __ ] can't go back there
so when i make enemies these are large
enemies then the small enemies are just
the people i piss off
um
you know if i'm not going to mention the
name but if if some
you know well-known internet personality
is is watching pre-teen girls twerk i
mean i gotta say something about that
well you know i get sued as a result so
anyway i make i make enemies
uh i've got the um
the cia and the fbi and the entire u.s
government because for two years i have
been preaching on stage you want to free
yourself from the government from paying
taxes go to cryptocurrency get yourself
a privacy coin and a distributed
exchange and those [ __ ] will never know
anything about your income and i preach
this why because i believe it first of
all i'm a libertarian most of us believe
taxes are theft
they are jesus god and why should i have
to work four months or three for the
government every [ __ ] year i'm not a
slave even though i'm treated like one
but in any case that's neither here nor
there i still have been preaching it so
loudly
that it not just pissed them off it
started scaring them but you don't want
to scare a big ass government you know
unless you're
a very slippery [ __ ] like myself
and and my wife janice
you know
you know catching us and holding us for
a long time is a difficult thing to do
so yeah
yeah yeah you're very good at thumbing
your nose at them though i have to give
you that much it is uh it is i
understand
you're under uh a bit of duress and you
obviously have your your issues with
these people but it is really fun
having a guy just out there
[ __ ] people oh yeah when you
have that many people aligned to take
you down and you're just flipping them
off and posing on a boat with guns
is sort of new to this life she's only
been with me seven years okay it's been
seven
years for her or do you feel
underdressed no no
and why no
well because we're free to come and go
as we want to yeah we're free we have
always been free even in that [ __ ]
jail i don't know if you saw those
pictures i was smiling i was joking we
were cracking jokes we got all the
prison cards involved that passes
cigarettes and beer and bought food
jesus christ when you have fun wherever
you are if you're honest and open and
love everybody which we do
so we are not please god do not think we
are under to rest
i might have misspoke i just meant under
pressure as far as these people are
constantly
uh you know kind of out to
add stress to your life and you have to
move a lot i i would find that stressful
myself personally but uh so what are
your thoughts right now on uh we got
like these uh red flag you know we have
a president
who's joking about red flagging people
taking guns uh things are getting very
spicy here in america what are your
thoughts about these uh the the red flag
laws and dan crenshaw
well jesus i mean anybody who follows me
even remotely you know once a month
cannot help but notice
i'm i am for individual freedom 100
there's there's nothing else because if
you're not free you're not alive you're
a slave well you're alive but what life
does a slave have
you are there's only two options you're
free or you're a slave
well janice and i are free and and as a
result
i get to say whatever i [ __ ] want and
i do it all the time i mean the uh the
federal bureau of investigations
cracking down now on conspiracy
theorists
if you believe in in their statement if
you actually believe that the u.s
government
lies and does malicious things to the
american public that's a conspiracy
theory and you can go to jail can you
[ __ ] believe that oh i mean you're
taking
they're taking our guns they're they're
taking our free speech
and they're selling us this nebulous
thing called security in exchange for
our privacies and freedoms and please
god you need to understand there is no
difference between privacy and freedom
because you cannot have freedom unless
you first have privacy yes
but i guess the segways into this
what do you think and what are your
thoughts of what went on and what's
happening with epstein
well you know here's the thing
for example one of the nice things about
the the irs
cracking down on conspiracy theorists is
if they're legitimate why don't they
crack down on those idiot conspiracy
theorists who actually believe that
epstein committed suicide those people
should be in jail
and who are those people there are
government they're the officials they're
the autopsy guy they're the prison
officials
everybody
so
this is a joke please god just listen
for one second to the facts
okay he had a cellmate
up until a few hours before he hung
himself the prison guards were told to
go home early the cameras were not even
positioned properly to see what was
going on in that area
bones were broken in his neck consistent
with
somebody strangling you with force
he told people that he thought people
were trying to kill him the inmates who
were who knew him said he was finally
adjusting and seemed quite happy and
content so please god
do anybody who believes that man
committed suicide
needs to move out of their mother's
house
you know it's it's it's true and uh it's
not only that it is a coordinated effort
because it's not just like cnn every
network i've been on has been having
quote unquote medical experts going well
no he could have still hung himself and
we don't know what he did but now
there's a lot of there's a lot of people
also a lot of people saying that
somebody like epstein would have had a
dead man switch right where he would
release stuff upon his death what do you
think about that
i i don't know i don't know if i didn't
know jeffrey but personally
uh never met him i certainly never had
dinner with him i'd be the last person
in the world to know whether he would
have had a dead man stretch
yeah right
your ass that i do
yeah and that's my point like when when
you know if you if you're if you're in a
situation someone and again it just
common sense it's not whether you would
know or not but if you if you're
somebody that had that much
incriminating stuff on very powerful
people you would think you would protect
yourself in the event of someone trying
to kill you you know
well absolutely and and the only way to
do that is to broadcast to those
powerful people directly
little tidbits saying here
you think i don't have anything
how about this
now no one will ever see this as long as
i continue to breathe
you should spend every last penny you
have to make sure i breathe as long as
possible that's that's the purpose of a
dead man switch
listen
i hate to be callous about humanity but
releasing that information to the public
is it going to do any good no
it's going to go on the corruption will
continue to go on it will cause my
instantaneous death so the only value in
this information to me is
as long as it is secret
i continue to breathe until i find a
natural end to this life
it's it's it is a mistake
to underestimate the intelligence of the
average american person
why
you can't judge their actions and
reactions while they're half asleep
to their same reactions and and
reactions when they're awake because
they will be different reactions i
promise you abraham lincoln understood
this right fully do not underestimate
the intelligence of the average american
and do not overestimate
the average american's laziness
right
or willingness
to just go along until they're no longer
willing and you're going to see some
woken up people with some high
intelligence that are really pissed off
and this will stop
now you know and and going on that and
seeing your life philosophy and
everything i i've read here that you're
you're throwing your hat into the 2020
uh presidential camp uh bid
yeah what do you have i ran in 2016
under the libertarian banner got in all
the debates including the national
debates
i had had a blast but i did it wrong
okay i was i was playing politics as
normal and now i'm not i know i'm not
going to win i know that nobody in the
libertarian party is going to win i know
that no third party is going to win
please god let's get real i can't be
elected president anybody who thinks so
stop using drugs or move out of your
mom's closet or something because
there's something wrong with you no
however i'm running
because it gives me the opportunity to
access the national stage
to try to wake people up a little more
that's it pure and simple yeah and
anything for the liberian libertarian
party we better than gary johnson so
well as a guy who jumped off the trump
train and broke both my legs i'm on the
mcafee train now
you have to you have to admit gary
johnson was the best entertainment the
libertarians have
ever put forth
entertainment i would agree with but
that's the problem is he was so he was
so non-threatening like you know when
when ron paul ran as a libertarian in
2012 right they actually were worried
about him taking votes away where they
wouldn't even mention him in polls
nobody was actually ever afraid of gary
johnson
well no but but he was entertaining i
mean when they asked him what do you
think about aleppo when he goes
to an aleppo i mean that's the crime
instant or or the video of him opening a
pickle jar where the lid had been
i remember that glued to the jar and he
had it between his legs and he was
trying to open it and it just looked
like public masturbation i mean it's
simple and when he and when he faked a
heart attack he faked a heart attack
with the weak thing
uh but so so what so like what what's
what's next for you i mean you say
you're living free what's your next
thing are you working on anything you
just you just live in life
what
i'm working on more [ __ ]
i can count
um
i'm always working on something i'm
always creating or developing and
some of the politics i can't talk about
others uh or boring but yeah i keep
myself busy and i keep and i'm running
my campaign i've got thousands of
volunteers in the states rob loges a
masterful campaign manager we've got
regional coordinate coordinators all
around the nation
so the campaign's going well and it
takes a reasonable amount of my time
uh you know twitter is is is sort of my
public voice
and when i feel like saying something
that needs to be said i choose twitter
as my medium
and to be fair to people i i have to
respond to comment cells what's the
point of saying something if i don't
listen to people's responses right so
that takes time
um i keep busy yeah well can't you like
maybe like that so anyway
about trump buying greenland because
sure
got questions i mean okay so
when you buy greenland what you actually
get you get all the land i mean like
including the land that's allegedly
owned by green landers which is all of
it or do you get just the government and
and if you do what value is it
uh do you get the people and can you
make them work for you i mean i got a
bunch of [ __ ] questions
and so tomorrow i'm going to ask them
again on my
well it is like a child it was a very
childlike thing to just be like we
should just buy greenland looks like
there's plenty of stuff up there like
it's just it's just a very childlike
spitballing in a meeting
i think i've seen a lot of trees i've
seen ice i think ice can be turned into
water i've seen mad max water is going
to be a problem in a few years
for god's sake please people wake up
wake the [ __ ] up